samedi 1er avril palais des sports
d'elancourt le club local de la gym
organise les demi finales du championnat
de france de gymnastique artistique
féminine
une première depuis deux ans chacun de
nous est d'organiser une compétition et
parfois ça arrive des fois c'est la
région où la zone ça dépend une
compétition à domicile à vrai plus pour
les 23 gymnastes du club présents pour
ce rendez vous selon la jeune prodige
élan courtoise de 17 ans mathilde de
terre ça change parce qu'on reconnaît
les agréent on connaît le matériel et
payal clapiers là pour nous encourager
sur le plan sportif les 300 meilleurs
gymnastes d'île de france se sont
produits sur quatre agrès le sol à
barres la poutre et le sol objectif à
chaque passage commettre le moins
d'erreurs possibles pour se qualifier
pour une grande compétition de fin de
saison
c'est un week-end important surtout
puisque c'est l'objectif c'est de
qualifier de ginette championnat de
france on sait un des deux plus gros
week-end de notre saison pendant cette
journée là j'ai mes longs courts mort
pas réussi à remporter six médailles
dont trois en or cinq gymnastes du club
sont déjà assurés d'être qualifiés pour
les championnats de france
un chiffre qui pourrait gonfler dans les
prochains jours pour atteindre 11
participants le classement officiel
définitif sera dévoilé cette semaine